So who's my guest this
week, the Data Scientist
and Facebook whistleblower,
Frances Haugen.
Is the personal cost
outweighed by the wider good?
This is the whistleblower's dilemma.
Frances Haugen calls her
decision to go public
with what she discovered
working at Facebook,
not plan A, not even plan B, but plan J.
But if it wasn't her initial intention,
it's now become central to her life.
Sharing tens of thousands
of internal documents
with the media and US law enforcement.
She wanted to show that Meta,
Facebook's parent company,
knew the harm it was causing
and carried on regardless.
The firm says Haugen's
claims paint a false picture,
and it makes no commercial
sense to allow harmful content
as advertisers don't want it.
But you can only really whistle blow once.
So what happens next?
And how do you keep up
the pressure for change
when you're now an outsider?
Here's what's coming up.
Do you think of Facebook as
having blood on his hands?
Yes, unquestionably.
Facebook's own documents say Instagram
isn't just bad for
teenagers, it's not just bad
for children, it's not just bad for them.
It's actually worse than
other forms of social media,
because TikTok is about performance.
It's about humor.
It's about doing things with your friends.
Snapchat is about faces,
about augmented reality.
Reddit is at least nominally
about ideas, right?
But Instagram is about
bodies and social comparison.
Frances, thank you so much for being here
for talking to me today and to all of us.
Thank you for inviting me.
Happy to be here.
Well, I mean, your voice
has become very famous.
Indeed, I wanted to start by
asking how it's been since
you've gone public as a whistleblower.
You know, it's so interesting.
I live in Puerto Rico and no
one ever recognizes me there.
And I've been, I've been
really shocked at like,
in some ways my life has
changed a lot, right?
Like I can sleep now at night.
So that's always a good thing.
I do interviews like this,
which is still surreal to me,
but you know,
it's enough separated from,
like, San Francisco that,
you know, I'm never
recognized in that context.
And so my life hasn't
really changed that much
on a day to day basis.
I'm amazed that I can
have my DMs open online.
Like you can DM me on Twitter and like,
I don't even get harassed.
And so I know that compared
to like female politicians,
I've had an easy experience.
Has that changed?
Was it different when
you first went public?
Oh, no and even when I first went public.
Okay.
I've gotten like maybe,
maybe 10 mean messages ever.
And like, I always respond to them, so.
No one troll me.
What's your technique?
I don't know, I'm always
willing to talk to my critics.
And how, do they usually calm
down a bit at that point?
They usually don't respond, you know.
Who'd have thought they'd be rude, hey,
but that's interesting.
You also say now you can sleep at night.
Yes.
Were you not sleeping, when
you worked at Facebook?
It's really hard living
with a secret, you know,
like I think one of the
things I had never really
contemplated before I came
out was whistleblowers,
in general, are not in very good shape
by the time they come out.
And like, one of the things that I had
that I think was very
different about my experience
versus most people's is I lived
with my parents during COVID.
And so I had people who
I completely trusted
who I could talk to things about.
And so by the time like I came
out or by the time I acted,
like I was already aligned
with like what I needed to do.
And I think for a lot of
people who are whistleblowers,
they live alone with a secret
where they know people's lives
are on the line and that
process really eats away at you.
And, you know, I know
that I did what I could.
And so there's a wonderful
release in that, right.
It's very easy to sleep at night then.
But I suppose with that, I mean,
and you were not sleeping.
You were stressed about what you knew.
We'll get into that.
Did you need a certain
level of grit, resilience
to actually go through
with it would you say
because of course, you know,
there are different types of whistleblower
in different circumstances.
Oh, unquestionably, we, actually I think,
as a society need to talk
more about the continuum
of whistle blowing, like in
the United States, you know,
you can't sign a contract
that prevents you from giving
information to Congress that
you believe is necessary
for Congress to do oversight.
You can be a very subtle,
quiet whistleblower.
It's just that people see
the few whistleblowers
that are out.
And so I think it's one of
these things where if you know
that what you need to do is necessary.
You know, I've always been
a long distance cyclist,
you know, you just put
on more miles, you know,
you just keep going and I'm really happy
with how things ended up.
Were you scared just before, you know,
what was that moment like?
Yeah.
I dunno even know what the moment was.
That you blew the whistle.
So I think there's like
different sets of moments.
So, while I was getting the
information out of Facebook,
I was very worried that I wouldn't be able
to get out the information
that was needed.
Right, that I knew that
this was very complicated
that if you didn't get a
representative set of documents
that, you know, you could criticize it
and say, this is not a full picture.
And so, until I was done,
I was very nervous that
I would not finish,
but I never worried about
consequences because like,
the number of lives that are on the line
is astronomical, right?
Like, I earnestly believe
there are 10 or 20 million
lives on the line in some
of the most fragile places
in the world.
When you say on the
line, what do you mean?
So so far we've had two major
ethnic violence instances,
genocides, that were, they were
facilitated by social media.
So, we had one in Myanmar
where over 200,000 people died.
We've had another one in Ethiopia
over the last couple of years
and we should not expect
that to be the end.
We should expect that to be the beginning.
And, but what's the difference
between using social media
to organize and using,
I don't know, email.
Oh, I'm so glad you asked.
That's a wonderful question.
So in email, the service
provider in general
is not telling you what order
to read your email in, right?
There are not algorithms
that give distribution
to some ideas and not to others.
In the case of Facebook,
the algorithm changes
they made in 2018 to go
from just trying to keep you
on the site as long as
possible to trying to optimize
for eliciting a reaction from you,
changed what content got amplified.
So, when they made that change,
political parties across Europe,
on the left, on the right
said, "Hey, we know you
changed the algorithm
"because it used to be we could
share the bread and butter
"of democracy, like a white paper
"on our agricultural policy
"and it didn't get the most comments,
"but we could see in the
statistics it got read.
"And now if we share
that exact same content,
it's just crickets."
And it's because the algorithm now says,
unless we can provoke a reaction
from you, it's not good.
And when you combine that
bias in the algorithm,
that extreme content gets
the most distribution
with linguistically diverse places
like the most fragile places on earth
are often linguistically diverse.
That means they're using
the most dangerous version of Facebook.
You know, no safety systems
'cause Facebook doesn't think
there's enough people
that speak that language
and societies are already fragile.
And so it's just very dangerous.
And we've seen, more and more times where
that gets weaponized in a
context that leads to tragedy.
I mean, it's safe to
say with this assertion
and other assertions,
Facebook does not agree
with your view of it.
I'm sure.
It says that, you know, it, you know,
the idea of promoting hate,
that's just not what advertisers want.
So why would they do that?
It doesn't make sense for business
and that they don't do that.
And also with some of the issues,
they recognize them and
they're working on them.
So what's interesting is we
really need to understand
that Facebook is not a single product,
that Facebook in different
parts of the world
are very different experiences.
Like when there's a multiple
hundred page report from the UN
that talks about how Facebook
was used by the junta
in Myanmar to inflame the genocide.
Like this is not a matter of contention.
Like it's been very well documented.
Facebook spun up war rooms
in the lead up to Ethiopia
'cause they knew the roles
that they were contributing to
and they knew that was a risk factor.
And yet they still see
themselves, not as a publisher.
Yes.
As a platform.
You've sat there while someone
from the Facebook oversight
board, talking to me about that.
Helle Thorning-Schmidt.
Yeah.
I mean, I don't know
if you think that board
is fit for purpose, they said
they were very interested
to meet and talk with you.
We've met with them.
Do you think it's fit for purpose?
So the oversight board is
a beautiful illustration
of how effective Facebook's
communications department is
because most people hear a name
like Facebook Oversight
Board and you're like, oh,
there's an independent
body that can ask questions
about Facebook.
They could ask is Facebook
inflaming violence
with algorithms.
Turns out that's not even in their remit.
That when you look at what
they're actually responsible for,
Facebook spent 120 million
dollars endowing a board
that can only look at
content censorship decisions.
So it's not fit for purpose.
It's not fit for purpose.
And we need an oversight board
that actually can do
oversight on the company
or we need something like
the Digital Services Act.
Which of course, you know,
countries around the world
are looking at different
ways at this at the moment.
I know you've been contributing to that.
Do you think you've done anything
that's made any changes though?
What points towards that?
So, Facebook has tried to expand coverage
of its language classifiers.
So in the Fall they rolled
out a different way of trying
to run their censorship system
so they could cover more
languages, which was one
of my core criticisms
was that not enough
safety systems existed.
They were misleading the public
about which safety systems
existed in which languages.
Facebook could have
released parental controls
for Instagram at any point
in the last 10 years.
People have been begging for
even basic parental controls
for 10 years.
They rolled out parental
controls for the first time,
maybe two months ago.
And you directly think
that's linked to what you-
I think so.
Took with you and showed?
A number of major leaders on
the Children's Rights Bill
in the United States have
said that the reason why their
bill is moving forward is
because of my disclosures.
And I think pressure
like that is part of why
they have parental controls today.
I mean, because let's talk about,
with particular reference,
Facebook, of course,
the parent owner of Instagram.
I mean, what would you say
to those individuals who talk
about the role for better parenting,
the role for autonomy,
and looking after young people online,
and that not necessarily
the platform should
be held responsible.
So, I'll give you an example
of how it works today.
And I'll give you an example
of something that's a really
low hanging fruit that they
could do that would put control
in the hands of kids, put control
in the hands of parents.
Today, Facebook has run studies
where they take a brand
new account, blank account
and they search for some
pretty innocuous stuff
like healthy eating, healthy recipes.
'Cause to be honest, we
could all eat healthier
and all they do is they
click on the first five
or 10 posts each day and
they follow any hashtags
they get suggested.
So there's no friends,
there's no other interest,
they're just clicking on
it, it's just the algorithm.
Within two or three weeks, you get sent
to pro-anorexia content
and pro-self harm content.
So, that's how the algorithm works today.
They're pushing kids towards
more extreme content.
What could be happening is
Facebook could start asking kids,
they already take all
the content on Instagram
and make into clusters.
So there's maybe 15,000 topics,
a hundred thousand topics.
They could go and poll kids,
they do things like this
already and say, does this
make your body image worse?
Does this make your make
you feel bad about yourself?
And if they saw a child who
was consuming a thousand,
2,000 pieces of content a
day that were about topics
that make kids depressed or
make them have worse body image,
they could ask that kid,
do you wanna keep looking at this content?
Or do you wanna see less of this content?
Because children are saying today,
I'm working with this therapist.
I'm trying to make better decisions.
And the content follows
me around Instagram.
Like I have to give up
my friends to be safe.
And I think that's like too high a bar.
But if my child was watching
a thousand bits of content,
2000 bits of content, that
takes quite a lot of time.
I would hope I knew
about that in some way.
That might sound very naive.
My child's pretty young at the moment,
but there is also that role there,
I suppose that some worry
that by putting it all
on the social media company,
without perhaps even going
against what you're saying here.
Yeah.
That that role is being
downplayed or ignored.
So I think one way to look
at is I think good parenting
plays like a vital role, but
one of the things we need
to keep in mind and I
lived with this experience
when I was a teenager,
you can feel confident
about your parenting,
but you need to ask the question,
are the parents of every
one of your kids' friends,
are they being as
attentive or is every kid,
is every parent in your kid's
school being that attentive.
But I think it's an uphill fight.
'Cause these products are
designed to be sticky,
to be addictive 'cause they're
more profitable that way.
I suppose there's a difference
between knowing something
is bad and keeping going
with it because it's good
for business and thinking
perhaps there isn't
or aren't that many things
you can do to change it.
Which is it with Mark Zuckerberg?
I think it's a question of,
I think Mark struggles with
so like I think he genuinely
believes that Facebook
is just a mirror, right?
That, you know, there's always
been bad things in the world.
There've always been kids
with eating disorders.
who have been bullied.
You know, this is just a
mirror and you're unhappy
because you can see it now and
he has trouble acknowledging
his power or the power of these products.
But you are saying he
just sees it as a mirror
rather than he knows it's doing harm.
I think it's the thing that
he tells himself a story
that he's surrounded by advisors.
And they're not telling him either.
And they're saying no, no, no.
The world has always had bad things.
Like you it's just a mirror.
It sounds like a cult.
It is a little, it definitely
has some management issues.
If you were Mark Zuckerberg,
do you think you should
be able to sleep at night?
I think he's really stressed.
Right, like I think the fact
that he has this vision,
that we're all gonna
live in the metaverse.
Right, think about that a little bit,
like the metaverse was a dystopian concept
in the original novel, right?
Like people's lives were so bad
that they went into these virtual spaces.
I bet it's really hard for
Mark to go to a restaurant.
Like, can you imagine
people like looking over
and glaring at you?
Do you think that they do though?
I think they do.
Like in, in Silicon Valley,
people are not pro Facebook.
I mean, you sound like
you're sympathetic to him
and yet at the same
time you couldn't sleep
because of what you knew
and you didn't obviously know everything.
I think hurt people hurt people.
And I think Mark has
been surrounded by people
since he was 19 years old who told him
he was doing a great job.
And so it's one of these things of,
we can demonize Mark Zuckerberg,
but it's not gonna make him heal faster.
It's not gonna like when
people feel attacked.
But he has the power.
He does have the power.
So that's not the issue.
He's the only one who has the power
because the voting structure
of Facebook is different
than most corporations in
that he holds 56% of the votes
for the company.
No one, but Mark Zuckerberg
can control Facebook right now.
Do you think he should go?
I don't think he, I don't
think the company can recover
as long as he is the leader of it.
And I think the fact that he
doubled down on the Metaverse
when I brought up issues around genocide,
like building, saying
we have enough people,
we have enough money, enough
people to hire 10,000 people
to build video games
instead of actually
making these systems safe.
I think that's a dereliction of duty.
I mean, the company is at pains to mention
40,000 moderators and that, you know,
they're spending a lot more on this,
giving more attention to it.
But of course, as you say,
you mentioned the Metaverse,
there's 10 billion, I
believe to be spent on that.
So, when my disclosures happened,
they increased the spending
from about two and a half,
2.6 billion per year to 5
billion a year, which is great.
On moderation?
On safety systems.
Safety, okay.
And great, that's a step
in the right direction,
but did you know they bought
back 75 billion dollars
of stock in the 12 month period
that's happening right now
so that they have enough
money lying around
to light on fire $75 billion,
but they could only spend
$5 billion on safety.
They have $10 billion
to spend on video games,
but they can't spend more on safety.
You talked about, of
course, what's been going on
in different countries and
the concerns that you had
about lives on the line.
But there have also been some
cases I'm not gonna name names
for reasons that you know, are obvious,
we're talking about children here,
but there have been examples
of children in both the US,
the UK, and I'm sure
elsewhere in the world
where they have taken their own lives
and the parents blame, you
know, Facebook, this company,
you know, as part of that Instagram,
they also blame some other
social media platforms,
I should say.
But do you think of with
that particular instance
with regards to young people,
do you think of Facebook as
having blood on its hands?
Yes, unquestionably.
Facebook's own documents say Instagram
isn't just bad for
teenagers, it's not just bad
for children 'cause remember there's kids
all the way down to eight and nine,
like parents have told me,
kids are using social media,
using voice to text as
young as eight and nine.
That it's not just bad for
them, it's actually worse
than other forms of social media
because TikTok is about performance.
It's about humor.
It's about doing things with your friends.
Snapchat is about faces,
about augmented reality.
Reddit is at least nominally
about ideas, right?
But Instagram is about
bodies and social comparison.
So you do see when those parents have said
what they have said about their children.
You buy what they're saying
about the role of those
companies, this company in particular.
Unquestionably, like the one
they broke my heart the most
was there was a father
of a child who died,
who I got to meet with.
And he said, "I don't know what I
"could have done differently.
"I took his phone away.
"Like, I saw that he was
looking at this content.
"I saw he was getting bullied.
"I took his phone away
and he ran away from home.
"And when we looked for him,
we couldn't find him anywhere.
"It wasn't any of his friend's houses.
"And the reason was cause he
fell asleep on a park bench
"and he had hypothermia.
"And so I gave him his phone back.
Like I don't know what I
could have done differently."
And that's what parents are facing.
They feel powerless because
these systems are designed
to be sticky.
They're not designed for children.
They're designed for adults.
It might seem a slightly old question.
Would you ever go back
there and try and improve it
and work there?
I still maintain, I still
encourage people to work
at Facebook because it is the most,
we have to solve the problem of Facebook.
But you weren't sleeping
when you worked at Facebook.
I mean, I wouldn't feel
like it sounds like a good
job move for me if we were having a chat.
I'm not having to hold those
lies in anymore, right?
But I suppose if you're
saying to people go,
you couldn't make the
change while you were there.
So, the way, the thing I
always say to people is
these systems are very complicated.
There are currently zero
classes you can take anywhere
in the world where you will
learn how Facebook's algorithms
work or the interconnection
of how the algorithms work
with the product choices.
And we need good people
to go into these companies
and participate with their eyes open
because the way the world learns.
It sounds like they're going to
'cause they're not gonna sleep, yeah.
I believe we will only
get better social media
if we engage in the process of
building better social media.
So if you were given the call, you would?
I would go back.
Had the call?
I've never had the call.
I, they don't really acknowledge I exist.
They'll definitely know your name.
Just looking across the
social media landscape,
what do you make of it may not happen,
but there's somebody like Elon Musk trying
to take over Twitter and grapple
with the free speech issue.
He's also talked about
reinstating, for instance,
Donald Trump's account.
What do you make of that?
And what he's said so
far about free speech,
there's some who have
expressed concerns about him,
Elon Musk, as a person having this power.
You know, I think it's so
hard to read Elon's actions
because he does so many,
he, at this, at one point
at the same time, he is able
to land rockets on the moon.
Upright, yep.
Upright, land them up and
down, all those things.
So, he must be good at
asking hard questions
and accepting hard answers.
'Cause if you're in denial on
the level of Mark Zuckerberg,
there's no way you're going to the moon.
Okay.
But he also does all these
wacky things on the internet.
And so it's this question of
like, which is the real Elon?
And so part of the reason why
I'm cautiously optimistic,
I don't know, is I think once
he gets inside the company
and he can see all the data
and he can talk to the people
and get a more robust picture,
I would hope that he would,
you know, there's a lot of the
things that I'm recommending
are around, looking at
behavior over content.
Because when we look at
things like saying, you know,
should you have to click
a link to reshare it?
How long should you have
to have that link open?
Clicking on a link before you reshare it
reduces misinformation by 10 or 15%.
These are interventions
that work in every language
in the world.
And so I'm cautiously optimistic
based on who his advisors are,
that there would be an opportunity
to do many of these things.
And part of why they
haven't been done to date
is they cut off little slices of profit.
And so, I think there's
opportunities to explore solutions
that weren't possible when
it was a public company.
But you know, time will tell.
Have you made friends with
other whistle blowers?
Do you know some?
I do know some other whistleblowers.
Is there a community of you?
They are very friendly.
I wouldn't say that we have that we have,
there might be an active
community, but I've talked
to a handful of them on an ongoing way.
I wonder if there's a kind of, you know,
sometimes when you take a leap.
Yeah.
Someone else who's taken a
leap before kind of steps
in and says, I know what
you're going through.
And you might wanna think
about this, this and this.
What's so interesting is
there's one whistleblower
who I've talked to, who has really,
who took a very different path than me.
And they went it very alone, right?
Like they, they have never accepted
any kind of support or assistance.
And like I very early on got,
or started working with
a whistle blowing lawyer
and they, whistleblower aid
throughout the United States.
And they were incredibly
beneficial in terms of educating me
on like, you think you
have made some choices,
but let me tell you about the consequences
of those choices, right?
Like, I had always intended
not to come out, right?
Like, that's part of why
the disclosures are so large
is that I wanted them
to stand on their own.
And because they were able
to take time and like talk me
through consequences, they
were like, your identity
is gonna be the juiciest
story in the world.
Like, and Facebook knows who you are.
Like they know who pulled
the doc, like which documents
and whatever.
I'm sure they know who you are.
And so I talked to this other person
who had not gotten the
same amount of handholding.
And it's just so interesting.
You know, every
whistleblower is different.
And the thing I would encourage
whistleblowers is like,
always ask for help.
People wanna help you.
And you don't have to be public.
I did wanna ask how you relax
when you're not blowing
whistles and keeping data
and then sharing it and
trying to tell the world
what you are concerned about,
what's keeping you awake.
You mentioned cycling.
Is that the main or what
else do you like to do?
I love the ocean.
And so I have not, I
don't have my bike set up,
but the ocean is beautiful
and we have snorkel equipment
and there's sea turtles.
Is that not the most wonderful thing?
And you can just lay there in the water
and like follow a sea
turtle and you're like,
nothing else matters.
So I'm very lucky.
That's a beautiful image to paint.
I mean I'm sure you've shared
some photos of it on Instagram.
My Instagram's only like the pictures
of me meeting people.
I'm not very good at, ironically,
I'm not very good at Instagram, so.
There you go.
That's the scoop.
Frances, thank you very
much for talking to me.
My pleasure, good to be here
It's been really fascinating
and thank you so much
for being with us.
Until we meet again, do
take care and goodbye.